a lot of news this morning we're gonna
start with this president Trump's former
campaign chairman Paul Manafort will be
in court this morning for the beginning
of his high-stakes criminal trial now
this marks a new public phase in Special
Counsel Robert Muller's 14-month Russia
investigation Manafort faces bank fraud
and tax evasion charges tied to his
lobbying work for a russia-backed
political party in Ukraine if convicted
he could serve life in prison
Paula Reed is outside the court house in
Alexandria Virginia with how the Russia
investigation looms over this trial
Paula good morning good morning these
stakes could not be higher for President
Trump or Special Counsel robert muller
as jury selection gets underway here at
federal court in virginia now mana fort
is the first Trump associate to face
trial in the Special Counsel
investigation this case will involve 35
witnesses in more than 500 pieces of
evidence in an attempt to prove that men
afford earn tens of millions of dollars
from his work with Ukrainian officials
they also say he allegedly hid
significant portions of that money from
the IRS and spent it on expensive homes
cars and clothes as a way to launder
that money now one of the witnesses who
is expected to testify is former Deputy
Trump campaign Chairman Richard gates
who is one of men affords former
business partners while there is nothing
in the charges related to Russian
involvement in the Trump campaign this
case it's the first big public test for
the special counsel now special counsel
Robert Muller had been hoping that mana
fort would flip and offer to share
anything he knew about alleged Russian
involvement in the Trump campaign but so
far he has not been willing to cooperate
and sources close to the case tell me he
is banking on a presidential pardon if
he is convicted Alex
Paula thank you